un alto oficial del departamento del
tesoro de eeuu anunció nuevas sanciones
contra siete oficiales rusos por el
intento de envenenamiento y el
encarcelamiento del líder opositor
alexéi navalni eeuu dice que muy
probablemente el servicio federal de
seguridad de rusia una de las agencias
más importantes de inteligencia de ese
país usó el agente nervioso nórdico para
tratar de envenenar a naval y eeuu
anuncia también que incluirá a 14
organizaciones vinculadas con la
producción de armas químicas y
biológicas en rusia a una lista negra
del departamento de comercio estas
sanciones fueron coordinadas con la
unión europea que también sancionará a
cuatro oficiales de inteligencia rusa
congelándoles sus activos fuera de rusia
y prohibiéndoles la entrada a la unión
europea entre otras cosas oficiales del
gobierno de eeuu afirman que este país
no está tratando de reiniciar las
relaciones con rusia ni tampoco de
escalar las sin embargo anunció que
es solo el inicio de una tanda de
sanciones adicionales en respuesta al
ciberataque solarwinds en el que hackers
rusos infiltraron y robaron información
confidencial de nueve agencias del
gobierno estadounidense y más de 100
empresas de este país